how long does it take to turn a good guy
with a gun
into a bad guy with a gun a good guy
with a gun
never turns into a bad guy with a gun
that's why that argument
[ __ ] sucks of course
person who has a gun who thinks they're
doing a good deed
by mowing down eight people 10 people
12 people a thousand people thinks
they're the good guy with the gun
that's why they're killing people for
grievance
revenge
maybe sport but that's why that [ __ ]
argument sucks good guy
bad guy [ __ ] is because
the bad guy with the gun never thinks
they're the bad guy
they never go up oh i'm the bad guy now
i'm gonna go be a bad guy with a gun i
was a good guy two minutes ago
but now i'm the bad guy with the gun so
let's go be a bad guy
they think they're the good guy always
always think they're the good guy oh i
was horny so i'll go shoot up some
massage parlors which is [ __ ]
who knows what this what this [ __ ]
idiot out in boulder's grievances
who the [ __ ] knows and who the [ __ ]
cares
a good guy with a gun never
turns into a bad guy with a gun in their
minds
they're always the [ __ ] good guy with
the gun
always that's the problem
[ __ ] them